when you're suffering you give up on the
very things that you want it the most so
when the suffering got too much my dream
died and pretty much I almost died with
it if I didn't find Navy Seals and
getting past that hump I would have
never been up here today you can't
outrun your demons they'll always know
where you're hiding I walk around life
with so-called headphones on my head man
I don't you know really wear them
obviously but I just have these ear
muffs on that I I silence out the noise
I silence out the Judgment those people
get in their head the most important
conversation is the one you have with
yourself you wake up with it you walk
around with it you go to bed with it
eventually you act on it and my
conversation was a bad one so the people
who I thought were up here in my life
these uncommon men I was putting myself
down here but over a period of time I
started realizing that I'm also uncommon
and I started those uncommon men off by
realizing that we all have this ability
in our mind Hey Kevin Carmichael and I
make these videos because I need them
because I don't always wake up and feel
motivated to go take on the day and the
thing that saves me that helps me every
day is being around people who are
thinking bigger who are changing the
world and it gives me a little more
inspiration to go after my mission and
so I hope this video helps you go up to
yours today too so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only David Goggins
we live in a world that we want to be as
comfortable as we can
and we wonder why we have no growth we
we wonder why when the smallest thing in
our life gets difficult we wonder why we
cower and we run away because we are
kind of living our I mean our whole life
is set that way our whole life is a set
set up in in the path of least
resistance
we don't want to suffer we don't want to
feel discomfort so the whole time we're
living our lives in a very comfortable
area there's no growth in that so for me
I realize that the reason I became 297
pounds is because that was comfortable
what was very uncomfortable was running
was very uncomfortable was being on a
diet was very uncomfortable was trying
to face things that I didn't want to
face
and I also realized when I was really
big I had no growth
why because I was living comfortable so
I realized for me to find growth I had
to face all these different things that
made me very very uncomfortable one
thing I faced was running
I absolutely hate it running
but I knew for me to grow
I wanted I had to do this thing every
single day I wanted to start callousing
my mind I wanted to start becoming a
better person and how you become a
better person how you gain mental
toughness how you become the person you
want to be is constantly facing the
things that you don't want to face
if you constantly run away from things
that you don't want to face how is their
growth
how is their mental toughness I can give
you a class all day long about self-talk
visualization eat an elephant one body
at a time but if you're never putting
yourself in a situation to actually
practice these things
you're never going to grow I can't put
you out there in a we're all going
through a battle in our mind
a warrior is not a person that carries a
gun
the biggest warrior ever going through
is right between your own ears
it's in your mind we're all going
through a war in our mind and we have to
call us our mind to fight that war and
and to win that war mind is so powerful
and I didn't realize it I went through
three hell weeks range of school Delta
IV selects and all this stuff this
incident I'm gonna explain to you right
now is where I realized we are only at
40 of what we are capable of
here I am right I did to this race
called bad water 135.
I Googled the 10 hardest races in the
world what came up crazy race in Death
Valley
summertime 135 miles
I knew nothing about ultra running
I thought you would like you know camp
out run 20 miles then one day they run
20 miles again until you get 135 miles
had no idea what I was doing
call the race director up he's like hey
have you run 100 miles
I was like what in a week or what what
are you talking about
he's like no in 24 hours or less
I said no he goes you got qualify to get
in this race
you have to run 100 miles in 24 hours or
less
he was trying to call my bluff I call
him up on a Wednesday he goes hey
there's a race in San Diego on Saturday
where's the 24-hour race where you run
around you know a track a one mile track
for 24 hours and if you get 100 miles
I will consider you in my race
[Music]
it really helps to be smart people
and I was not smart in this situation
I saw I did the math it's about a 14
something minute mile
I can do that
anyway I show up on Saturday with the
blue launch here Rich crackers mileplex
and my ex-wife
and every mile I'm gonna see her I'm
gonna grab some Ritz crackers and some
mileplex
I don't know what the hell I'm doing but
it's Bliss that whole ignorance is bliss
thing
so I get to 70 miles pretty damn fast
I get a 70 miles like 12 13 hours
we think happens to your body we haven't
trained for that kind of mileage
a lot of bad things about thoughts in
good shape it was amazing
so I hadn't gone to the bathroom at all
I sit down big mistake
I sit down this blue lawn chair I sit
down looking at my ex-wife I'm seeing
like three or four of her
this is not good
so I'm trying to play it off
because
I know where I'm about to go
so I'm sitting there and when you
haven't gone to the bathroom or
dehydrated your nutrition is all jacked
up
you sit down you gotta go to the
bathroom now
so I look at my ex-wife and go do you
love me
she says yes
why
I go because I'm gonna
take a [__] on myself right now because
I can't stand up because my blood
pressure's all messed up
so I'm sitting there literally
pooping up my back and peeing blood down
my leg
she's a nurse so she's concerned
and
I'm telling you right now there's one
thing you never want to hear as a black
person
she said you're starting to turn white
so
I'm sitting there
and I'm all jacked up
and I'm like okay
how in the world am I gonna I got 30
miles to go
I should quit
but I didn't
what I started doing
through this whole process
was I started to study myself in the
dark times
so instead of just quitting real fast
I see no I'm going to quit but not right
now
so I sat back for a second
and I said let me get some water let me
hydrate let me clean my stuff up a
little let me get some nutrition
I wasn't dizzy
it's okay
my feet are all messed up
let me see if I can walk
I'm gonna walk one mile and then I'll go
home that'll be a great accomplishment
for me 71 miles
so I took this massive thing and I
started breaking it down into small
chunks
and as I started breaking it down to
small chunks I started realizing
maybe I'll walk one more mile
but at the pace I was walking
I wasn't going to make the time
so this is when I realized that whole 40
percent rule those you who write you
know red can't hurt me you understand it
basically the 40 rules when we have a
governor on our brains like a governor
on a car
a car may say 130 but if you put a
governor on a car it can only go 101.
we do the same thing to our brains
I was born with limited Horizons
born on our side of the tracks I didn't
think I could be anybody
so my governor was myself
so once you take that governor off you
have Limitless Horizons I was in the Air
Force for about four years and my big
thing was I want to be Air Force prayer
rescue men some of the best Medics on
the planet Earth as I got in the program
I started realizing that they had this
thing called Water conference basically
they make you very uncomfortable
underwater so I realized at that point
in time that I hated
being on the water I hated holding my
breath for six weeks I hung in the
program I didn't sleep at all for fear
of going back to the pool for fear of
drowning in my head about six weeks in
we had this physical and they realize I
have sickle cell trait
back in the day I used to lie about
whatever made me feel insecure on my
official paperwork out of Pet Rescue
Training it has David Goggins left on
the medical but the truth of the matter
is I left because I quit I had to find a
different job in the Air Force in four
years beating the Air Force I gained 125
pounds I get out of the Air Force and
I'm working for a job spraying for
cockroaches 40 Restaurants I was in
charge of I go in at nighttime and I
spray I would stop at Steak and Shake
get a large chocolate milkshake I would
go across the street to 7-Eleven get a
box of mini Donuts I'm way home I'll be
popping Donuts like Tic Tacs I would get
home turn the TV on this is my routine
start taking a shower and listen to the
TV as I'm showering this particular day
I started hearing Navy Seals
stuff is trading I was hearing it cut
out between the water hitting my ears so
I came out of the shower at the end of
the show this command officer gives a
speech he says we live in a society
where mediocrity is often rewarded these
22 men to test mediocrity I invent this
thing called the accountability mirror
when I was growing up and I got a chance
to go into that mirror and look at
myself and call myself out I'm afraid of
this I'm afraid of that being raw and
real about who I am and about what I'm
hiding from and so to overcome all this
my bright idea was to try to become the
one thing I was afraid of on the other
end of suffering
is a life that many people don't know
even exists it's a beautiful world
because we because like like the 40 rule
we all live in this world where our
brains are keeping us in this box
outside that box on the other edge of
suffering which is all the others of
that 40 percent
is a world that's endless of opportunity
but we are afraid to go outside that box
because in that box it's comfortable
that's where all of our nice stuff you
know that's where the nice four-lane
highway is at I know where the restrooms
are at I know where the gas stations are
at outside that box man God gives you a
shovel
it says Man start digging that's not fun
but when you dig you dig your own path
to all kind of stuff that's unknown and
that's why I started realizing man like
on the other end of this it's some
beautiful stuff so I got outside my box
and I was man
300 pounds now look at me I'm 185 pounds
and on the other side of the box was all
this stuff and I know it's over there
until I climbed the wall and saw it so
what wall are you climbing now
man right now I've climbed a lot of
walls there's no more walls anymore
the reason why is because I know how to
climb
I was trying to figure out how to climb
before I got all the right gear man we
got the ropes I got the shoes I got the
chalk I got the harnesses I'm good I'm
not scared to climb anymore I go to the
Rock hammered in
I got my belay and I'm good to go
so you got to figure out how to climb
first and that's all we all have a
different way of climbing that's why
there's a lot of books out there um
mental toughness it's all crap why
because it's a Cookie Cutter Way life
isn't cookie cutter like 3.14 is pi
it's how you figure out equations we're
all different equations we all come from
we all have a story
we'll have to strengthen our mind to
figure out our own equation once you
figure out your own equation in life you
can then start picking away and how to
be better but you first have to figure
out your equation in life once you
figure that out man you can do anything
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there what was the greatest lesson your
mom taught you growing up honestly the
greatest lesson she ever taught me is a
lesson that she's done she doesn't know
how much she taught me
because
she wasn't much in the teaching mode my
dad took her soul but what I did as a
young kid is I observed
everybody I wasn't really smart in the
books yeah but I was real smart when it
came to life yeah and I was able to sit
back and watch her mistakes I was able
to see
how she struggled through life and how I
don't want to struggle through life
and I was able to see
she never picked me up the biggest thing
she did for me and this is honest to God
truth and she doesn't even know she did
it
when I would bust my ass and I would
fail yeah when I was at the bottom of
the sewer
she never picked me up
she never gave me that cookie and said
hey son you know it's gonna be okay
never she didn't have time for that
and sometimes she gets upset when I talk
about my past because it paints her out
to be not the best mom if I had any kind
of mom in that kind of environment
I would have never made it because
she forced me for every reason
she forced me
to you better figure this out
or you're going to be a statistic wow
and this is something that she didn't
sit down and tell me I realized this
this is the world that is in front of me
and what most people do is they see this
world
and they look at it as an excuse to get
out of it yeah I started looking at it
is this is the ultimate training ground
for the rest of my life
I have all these valuable lessons
because if you look on the world right
now today is that a nice place
but I'm very prepared for it yeah you
are I prepared for it I'm prepared for
all the failure coming my way
I'm prepared for everything my way and
that's the biggest lesson that she
taught me by not teaching me by never
saying it's going to be okay matter of
fact she told me exactly opposite life
sucks
that's what she knew there was the truth
if you really can't hurt me I'd gone
into detail about my first times in my
race
the the race I wasn't trained for at all
and I went out there and spent 100 miles
around one mile track when I got to mile
70 and everything went South I mean it
went South I've been through three whole
weeks waiting to school some of the
world's hardest tree in the world and
this was the most pain I've been in my
entire life
when I sat down in that chair and went
to the bathroom myself and everything
went South
but I had 30 miles to go
and I was in the worst state of my life
and I will get too deep into it but when
I was able to go 30 more miles in the
worst Shape of My Life
that's when I talk about it in the you
know you can't hurt me the whole mental
governor
the whole mental Governor got removed
and that's when I realized that a human
being is able to do some of the most you
know horrific things out there we are we
are built very different like a lot of
us
you know we're we're we're taught
everything how to read how to write how
to drive a car how to cook how to clean
but very few of us are taught
how to survive when the rug gets pulled
from underneath us and we have to find
more very few of us are taught how to
fight
and at that moment that 30 miles was
about 10 years of life
that I lived in 30 miles and I learned
how to fight in the most in in the
hardest of times in the worst Shape of
My Life most of us fail in life because
we're afraid of what everyone around you
is thinking that's a hundred percent
truth so we live by the narrative
of other people
when I first called a recruiter to be a
Navy SEAL and I was 297 pounds the first
recruiter looked at me and said
you're not going to be able to make this
man so what he was doing was he's
projecting his energy on me he knew he
couldn't be [__] Navy SEAL
so God helped this black guy because I
was only the 36th African-American to
make it through in over 70 years
how does black fat guy go make it
through in my
you wouldn't even want to try so he's
projecting this so a lot of us who are
negative people all we do is Project how
we feel on other people
so what happens is there's a lot of
negative people walking around the
planet Earth who are afraid to try
because everybody a lot of people are
very negative in this world so we are
afraid to fail why I told you man I
shouldn't even tried it dude just chill
out relax why are you so crazy why are
you so obsessed so all that stuff drives
the the quitting mind I call it the Mind
wants to quit the mind is tired
the mind is tired the mind's deserving
the Mind thinks it's very deserving so
yes the the biggest problem in this
world is other people not yourself it's
other people
in your head they are puppet mastering
you pretty much on your life and is that
why you're you've talked a lot in this
podcast about getting rid of noise Quiet
alone is is that part of that equation
it's it's all a part of it yeah because
I realized once I was talking to myself
the right way
and all this wasn't in my mind wow I
went from this piece of kid who thought
he was dumb not successful insecure who
stuttered when I first saw somebody to a
person who can now do all these things
just because I now control my own mind
and I don't care a lot of people say
they don't care
they care like my my son says I don't
care and every time he says it I don't
care it means he can yeah
when you get to the point where you
really don't care you don't have to say
you're dangerous
you become very very dangerous I'm not
saying don't care like I don't care if I
do that no when you don't care about
other people and how they view you about
how you walk how you talk how you dress
where you want to go with your life
you know growing up I didn't want to
tell anybody I want to be in the
military because why some of my black
friends I was afraid of what they think
you know why you want to join the
military man
do that I was afraid of what other
people thought about me so now
when I go in the military I know you
want to join the military I ain't tell
you guys afraid what you thought
once again man you're allowed other
people to Shackle your mind and so it's
so it's the worst thing in the world
what power have you found in the
darkness first before I answer that
question I want to say everybody listen
to this
um
I'm the happiest man on the planet Earth
so people may take this and as so many
people do we live in a very weakened
Society
so when they hear a throwback guy like
me from back in the ancient days of of
Garanimals they often think this guy is
just whatever so if you think that I'm
some unhappy guy you're wrong haven't
lived the life I've lived and seeing the
other side not being afraid to attack
what was in front of me has made me
happy basically what the dark side is is
we all have
a cookie jar and we all have a jar of
its official name it's a jar of man
we're just
it just ain't going right
and in hell week what they do in hell
week because this is where I really went
to the dark side
what they do in hell week is they
design hell week to find your flaws and
they do a really good job of that it's
130 hours of continuous training you may
get two hours of sleep and they beat
this [__] out of you and find everything
wrong with your mentality and then they
start hell week
and that's the beauty of it and for me
I'm not some not you know nasty
god-given guy you know I don't have a
great bit of talent in anything
so what got me through horrible times
was the dark side
was I created my name is David Goggins I
created Goggins Goggins is the guy that
can take anything you put in front of
them you want to break my legs so be it
I have a way of going to a place like I
did in that race
where all the pain and suffering that
they put on top of me in hell week
I will reverse that pain and suffering
and I will take your soul
so every instructor that put me through
budge my job what drove me
was I wanted you to go home that night
after you beat the living out of me and
I smiled in your face
I wanted you to feel worse than I did
and you were going home to a nice warm
bed with your wife or your kids in a
nice meal and I was still out there in
the grip suffering for another 100 hours
I want you to think about me knowing
that I'm comfortable being very
uncomfortable and I want you to think
about when you went through hell week
how uncomfortable you were and how bad
you wanted to quit
knowing I'm not thinking that wrong way
so the dark side is something that I've
designed
it's the evil place I can go that very
few things can hurt me I use the hurt
you're trying to put on me I flip it
upside down and use it you try to use it
for Kryptonite
no
it's power pillars for me I'm using it
for strength I just flip negative into
positive that's all it is every morning
I wake up it's not just about working
out but for me working out has been a
very big part of my mental growth
so for me if I am not challenging myself
every day and I swear to God people will
not believe it I was over almost 300
pounds twice in my life
person that does that twice in his life
does not enjoy cardiovascular activity
okay yeah so people can put anything
they want to in their head I did realize
one thing
the things I don't enjoy that I still do
that's where growth is at and that's for
me the only place growth is at is in
that very uncomfortable you know in that
uncomfortable Zone yeah so I have to
visit it every single day so when you
say visit it every day what sort of
things are you doing daily to push
yourself so for instance today I woke up
I just got to London
very difficult to run around this place
so someone said hey you can run around
out here like around this one mile block
and I'm like you know what I'm not doing
that so I went down to the gym and
there's this like
crazy elliptical trainer but it's not a
normal elliptical trainer it's one that
you like almost self-power is very yes
no electric no yeah very difficult yeah
so I got on that thing and I realized
man this sucks and that's like two
minutes like I don't want to do this
so right then I realized hmm
it looks like we're gonna be here for a
while so I did that for two hours and 45
minutes wow yeah so
I'm not saying do that but that's
something I did today once my mind said
you know what let's not do this today
I said well since we're my my mind went
there I redirected it and said just for
having that weak thought
we're gonna be on here for a while I
want to know how have you evolved in
your relationship with suffering and
discomfort so think about when I say
suffering people cringe
people that's the that's the one word
whenever I post about it people cringe
it's not about suffering how people may
look at suffering like you have to just
go to a place that's just every day of
your life is suffering
you have to tap into suffering every day
of your life because we have so much
scarring that we have to clean up
you have to look at suffering as almost
like I look at failure
to succeed you must fail
in failure and in suffering all the
answers are in there all the answers to
all the test questions the test is your
life
all the answers are in there you don't
have to live in suffering and pain and
failure all the time
yet to learn I need to visit it like
people hate working out
you're only going to visit working out
maybe an hour a day 23 other hours of
the day you're not in it
but how you become in shape is you must
visit suffering visit working out one
hour a day visit suffering one hour a
day visit your past failures one hour a
day the relationship with it is the
answers are in there
they they are in there within the
suffering go in there
and I caught the live autopsy the live
autopsy how you find out someone died
they crack you open after you're dead
how you can live is do it while you're
alive go back in your brain crack it
open while you're alive don't wait until
you're dead to figure out why you died
do it while you are living
go in there go into the suffering go
into the pain of your life and say why
did this suck for me so bad
why am I afraid of all this stuff why
have I shut down the whole world
I guarantee I'll tell you why you shut
down the whole world it's in these Nooks
of the suffering within your brain in
the scarring
are all the answers
to why you are on the couch feeling
sorry for yourself they lie within the
scars
visit them for at least an hour a day
study them and then you'll find out more
about yourself you will then grow
so don't look at us every day I suffer
go into it an hour a day learn from
yourself learn from Life learn from your
failures learn from your insecurities
learn from your self-doubt don't just
say I'm afraid to jump off an airplane
what makes you afraid of it study it
that's why I studied my mind why I
became so powerful in the mind is
because I realized I was weak
so instead of running away from the mind
I dove into and say what is making me
weak oh this makes sense I Came From
Hell
I came from a place that beat me down to
nothing which is why I'm afraid
all this makes sense so systematically
one by one I went back and met every
single person in my mind every situation
I went one-on-one with them again
in my mind and say okay
let's now revisit this and that's how
you do it that's how it works your mind
is so powerful and I didn't realize it I
went through three hell weeks range of
school Delta IV selection all this stuff
this incident I'm gonna explain to you
right now is where I realized we are
only at 40 of what we are capable of
here I am right I did to this race
called badwater 135.
I Googled the 10 hardest races in the
world what came up crazy race in Death
Valley
summertime 135 miles
I knew nothing about ultra running
I thought you were like you know camp
out run 20 miles then one day they run
20 miles again until you get 135 miles
had no idea what I was doing
call the race director up he's like hey
have you run 100 miles
I was like what in a week or what what
are you talking about
he's like no in 24 hours or less I said
no he goes you got qualified to get in
this race
you have to run a hundred miles in 24
hours or less
he was trying to call my bluff I call
him up on a Wednesday he goes hey
there's a race in San Diego on Saturday
where's the 24-hour race where you run
around you know a track a one mile track
for 24 hours and if they get 100 miles
I will consider you in my race
it really helps to be smart people
and I was not smart in this situation
I saw I did the math it's about a 14
something minute mile
I can do that
anyway I show up on Saturday with the
blue lawn chair Ritz crackers mildplex
and my ex-wife
and every mile I'm gonna see her I'm
gonna grab some Ritz crackers and some
mileplex
I don't know what the hell I'm doing but
it's Bliss that whole ignorance is bliss
thing
so I get to 70 miles pretty damn fast I
get a 70 miles like 12 13 hours
we think happens to your body we haven't
trained for that kind of mileage
a lot of bad things my thoughts in good
shape it's amazing
so I had gone to the bathroom at all
I sit down big mistake
I sit down this blue launcher I sit down
looking at my ex-wife I'm seeing like
three or four of her
I'm like oh I lost this is not good
so I'm trying to play it off
because
I know where I'm about to go
so I'm sitting there and when you
haven't gone to the bathroom or
dehydrated your nutrition is all jacked
up
you sit down you gotta go to the
bathroom now so
I'm sitting there
and I'm all jacked up
and I'm like okay
how in the world am I gonna I got 30
miles to go
I should quit
but I did it
what I started doing
through this whole process
was I started to study myself in the
dark times
so instead of just quitting real fast
I said you know I'm going to quit but
not right now
so I sat back for a second
and I said let me get some water let me
hide you let me clean myself up a little
let me get some nutrition
I wasn't dizzy
it's okay
my feet are all messed up
let me see if I can walk
I'm gonna walk one mile then I'll go
home that'll be a great accomplishment
for me 71 miles
so I took this massive thing and I
started breaking it down into small
chunks
and as I started breaking it down to
small chunks I started realizing
maybe I'll walk one more mile
but at the pace I was walking
I wasn't going to make the time
so this is when I realized that whole 40
rule those of you who already know red
can't hurt me you understand it
basically the 40 rules we have a
governor on our brains like a governor
on a car
a car may say 130 but if you put a
girlfriend on the car going to go 101.
we do the same thing through our brains
I was born with limited Horizons
born on our side of the tracks I didn't
think I could be anybody
so my governor was myself
so once you take that governor off you
have Limitless Horizons
so here I am now sitting in this chair
walk 75 I'm at 80 miles but I'm not
coming to time the most amazing thing
happens
the brain the mind the soul the spirit
it all connected it's never happened
before like this in my entire life
I ran the next 19 miles
I ran about 10 minute mile I finished
101 miles
in 19 hours and six minutes
I'm going to save you how the story ends
because it is real foul it ends in the
tub with me peeing Coca-Cola out of
myself it was blood
and it was the best film I had in my
entire life I'm not sadistic but when
you push yourself to that level and
accomplished something you thought was
impossible what happens to your body and
mind is something I can't really even
explain what got you up out of the chair
honestly I create this thing called the
cookie jar as I went through my
suffering in life to become who I was
and the cookie jar was every time I
failed everything so many times in my
life and earlier and I would succeed I
would fail and I would succeed I had to
figure out how to succeed through
failure and I put a bunch of cookies in
the cookie jar the cookie jars or things
when I started to get the what was me
mentality which we all still get even
though you know you could be very
successful I reached it and I saw this
is my childhood and this is what I did
to overcome that because a lot of times
when you're in hell you forget how great
you really are because at that moment
you're suffering so you don't you don't
think about the great things that you've
done I take time to really calm my brain
down when it's stressed out and remember
where I came from and said okay no we do
this we can do this through a calm
patient mind figuring out how to do it
so I figured out how to do it how to get
salt electrolytes get some food get some
hydration back in me get my blood
pressure the point where I can stand up
that was the first mission I gained
about 50 pounds back it's about 250
pounds this is a story about the mind
I'll go through it real quick so I
didn't put running shoes on for about
nine months ten months I was overseas
deploying came back into Free Fall
school I was at military Free Fall
Sports in the trail marks the Trail's
twin brother we got the news that an
incident happened where everybody died
and they couldn't find Marcus a trail so
I got the car my job is to tell Morgan
to Trail his twin brother who was also a
Navy SEAL because his brother might be
dead
four days later they found Marcus and
troll live what I did was I went online
Google's you know different events this
event came up on the bad water 135
burned 35 mile race through Death Valley
in the summertime I didn't know that was
even unique possible to run that far
above the stage race I thought you'd
like put your shoes on ran 15 miles
stuff a barbecue camped out and then did
it again the next day it was a 40-hour
race I went out there and basically to
raise money for a Special Operations
Warrior Foundation
so I called this guy up named Chris
tossman Chris Carson was a race director
he said to me basically you have to run
100 miles and 24 hours left to qualify I
never run past 20 miles in my entire
life and up until now I probably ran 20
miles this entire year so he says I call
him up on a Wednesday he says you know
what there's a race on Saturday and if
you run 100 miles in 24 hours I will
consider you my race
so I wasn't real smart growing up and
obviously I went real smart right now
so I did the math the math I could look
you know less than 15 minute mile says
you know I can walk this
this isn't made my entire life went out
there about 250 pounds and I get to mile
50. so it's in San Diego in November so
what a one mile track we where you go as
as you know as many times you can't run
one mile track for 24 hours I get to
mile 50 in about 12 13 hours I sit down
I see this blue launch here I saw my
ex-wife every single mile I got Ritz
crackers in myoplex with my nutrition I
was a muscle here so I drink a lot of
mileplex back then so basically here I
am drinking mild Place Ritz crackers by
mile 70 I haven't gone to the bathroom
one time no water that mileplex tastes
like hell and the Ritz cracker is a ball
in my mouth
where I really realized today so I'm
already Navy sealed this is not realize
that we only use 40 of our mind it's
when I started going crazy with mindset
and being a scientist of the mind we go
I'm at Mile 70 I look at my ex-wife B
sit down and I have to go in the
bathroom for 12 hours what must you do
go to the bathroom
so I sit down and look at her it's the
first of all my entire life set them out
I'm happy I'm feeling good and I can't
get to go to the bathroom it's literally
for me in the stage so look at her and I
said honey do you love me she goes why I
go because I can't stand up my blood
pressure's all messed up I go and take a
shot of myself right now so I went back
my back and started peeing blood down my
leg and my wife my ex-wife's like oh my
God you gotta stop
this is what I realized throughout my
whole life all the bad times are the
good times you know I'm not going to
quit yet
let me get better let me fix my blood
pressure let me get some potassium
sodium nutrition in my body let me see
if I can fix myself so I said if I can
just walk one more mile after being in
the worst shape of my entire life this
would change everything for me mentally
going forward from this kid who came
from dirt nothing who couldn't read so
he was in a junior in high school and is
now here I went I walked a mile I said
hmm maybe if I can walk one more block
maybe [__] another mile at Mile 81 my
extra I think that means you're not
gonna make the time
when your mind knows it's not going to
quit and this is what I found out this
is my 40 rule when your mind knows it's
not going to quit your body will adapt
to whatever is in front of it I end up
running 20 more miles I did 101 miles in
19 hours and six minutes in that one day
change that one 19 hours it wasn't still
a train he wasn't Ranger school wasn't
Delta Force everyone in that crap it
went through it was this 19 hours and
six minutes that forever changed my life
to know that we as human beings are
capable of anything and we don't need
any special kind of parents or tools to
get there what is something that you
learned about yourself through your
process or your journey
I learned I was leaving a lot on the
table and that's what scares me the most
I I'm I'm good now but what haunts me is
that at 24 years old
I was 300 pounds and if I didn't make a
right turn
if I decided to just give in to the
feelings I had
I would have died a three or four
hundred pound man working some
minimum wage job in my casket never
knowing
that I was this guy and with fear so I
believe in God and what scares me the
most is I believe that God
in my own mind I'm a big visualization
person so so it keeps me going is like
visualizing it's not true but it helps
me I believe that God had this big chart
in heaven
and when you get there if you earn your
right to get there you get there and
have him and you get there let's say I
walked about 300 pounds and God says hey
man great job you made to heaven
and he rips this page down from Brian
Underwood and now it says David Goggins
his chart he rips it down
throws that paper to the side and he
says look at this and I'm reading it I
go what is this
he goes how much do you weigh 300 pounds
what did you do I was a pest control guy
for 40 years
he says this is what you were supposed
to be
you know what I'm saying
185 pound person
be able to run 205 miles break the
pull-up record motivate people energize
people make them driven make him
passionate make him find more
so am I in heaven or in hell
that's what motivates me
it scares me also
because I believe that we are all
leaving a lot a lot on the table
and now when I go to heaven when I want
God to look at me and say is
as you were living
I'm the all-knowing man I had to get a
damn marker out and write more as you
were living
that's what I'm saying
I want to impress him
that's what I'm here for
I want to do the impossible I believe
that you have to build belief
is like there's an after-school special
belief where the mom says believe in
yourself and that's all great but
there's also a built belief
and the built belief is one where you
are constantly like for me I came from a
bad place How I build belief is through
the the daunting tasks
I put myself through so that's proof
positive that I can
so it correlates and that's how this
piece of kid I once thought I was
don't believe by saying hmm
I was in three hell weeks I went to
Ranger school I tried out for Delta
selection undeniable stack of proof that
is proof so whenever you think whenever
you think you can't
confidence comes from the thing that you
built
you must build belief you must build
confidence it can't be like hey
um I'm Gonna Knock that [__] out
you gotta look over here and say
I can knock that [__] out
it's belief and it's built on what you
put in to yourself there's like this
Allure that you have where it's with
anything any type of keynote from David
Goggins any type of video from David
podcast what do you think it is what do
you think it is that attracts people to
your content I think it's my take it or
leave it kind of mentality
where I don't really think about your
feelings I don't really care about what
you think or what you think about me or
if you're soft if you're weak if you're
hard if you're an alpha if whatever the
hell you are I just don't really care
and I'm gonna say would I believe is
going to get you better it may make you
pissed off at me in the interim
but in the long term if you really think
about what I'm saying I'm saying things
to you that I had to listen to and you
know tell myself and it's just sometimes
hard truth sucks but what I'm most
impressed with is training the brain
would you say to those of us that are
listening and watching today that every
time you would get through a day of hell
week or just a day of training whatever
it was that the Mind does almost like a
muscle The Voice does change and you can
train the negative voice
the mind as you know is not a muscle but
it almost is yeah it really is if you
stop going to the gym right your muscles
will atrophy yeah if you stop training
your brain same thing will happen so I
learned to callous over I did 4030
pull-ups in 17 hours to break the guest
bigger world's records your hands become
very calloused
calluses protect your hands what I've
learned to do is through mental
hardening is callous my mind I had a
victims mentality I learned to callous
My Mind Over the victim's mentality
and you have to be willing to put
yourself in very difficult situations at
all times to be able to do that so my
big takeaway of life is
if you're constantly taking the easy way
out you never go cash your mind I was at
MIT they called a person like me to MIT
to speak to some of the biggest head
guys on the planet oh yeah these guys oh
brains so awesome I was on this panel
and you know I'll talk about it in my
introduction of my book
and all these brainiacs were there and
they called me in like you say
I didn't go to college for this but
they're all theorists
I'm a practitioner that's why I asked
you absolutely that's the difference and
so they're all sitting there all these
great smart Minds from MIT are asking
these brilliant guys questions I ain't
say a word I'm like I'm intimidated
right but I know that half of what
they're saying is wrong because with
these theorists that even though they're
very smart what these theorists did was
they took a poll on normal people
and this is what you get of course this
is what we cannot do so if there was
love telling you what we cannot do this
is what we can do right so one person in
the crowd asked me a question why aren't
you saying anything I said pretty much I
disagree with almost everything up here
on this panel because I'm living proof
that everything that they're pretty much
saying is not true that's right because
you were an average person I was a below
below sure sure a low average person I
was a chameleon living in life who right
could barely get by so I know that they
were taking the normal mindset of people
they weren't talking about the one
percenters the people who wanted like
there's no tomorrow and so that's what I
started realizing was we have theorists
and we have practitioners so what's in
my book is from going into the to the
dungeon and when you're in those points
where you want to quit
and not quitting and seeing how the mind
starts to operate in those moments of
fear anxiety self-doubt insecurities and
that's where you learn to fix it yeah
you don't fix it in 72 Degree weather
right drinking the milkshake watching TV
you fix it by going into the environment
you made military history though you
finally got into the military you had to
lose what was like 180 pounds or
something like that yeah so after I got
in the Air Force I had some setbacks in
the Air Force I realized I was afraid of
the water
so I want to be Air Force Special
operator Air Force prayer rescue men and
I worked my butt off to do it and you
know I got in the water and I realized
I'm not I'm not you know mean the water
no fun right so I went from 175 pounds
to 297 pounds in three years yeah and
then I sat at home and all those
insecurities from my high school years
came back you know just everything I was
like man I'm nobody wasn't good enough
right not feeling good enough making a
thousand dollars a month praying for
cockroaches right and I came home from
work one day and I watched this you know
it was so on Discovery Channel History
Channel something like that but it was
Navy SEAL class Butch class 224.
going through training and it was
nothing but water and they're going
through hell week and they're freezing
and people are quitting left and right
and I sat down at 297 pounds with a
chocolate milkshake and a box of mini
chocolate donuts and I'm washing these
amazing men going through training and I
felt like man I've I have to now really
start to overcome my fears because I
felt so small every day I had this
haunting voice in my head saying you're
nothing you're nothing and
I had to start conquering myself yeah
and I lost 106 pounds in less than three
months there's several days I don't want
to do
I procrastinate like
this is one of those days man I put my
shoes in my socks and my shorts on every
day woke up this morning just stared at
him didn't want to do didn't know why I
was doing this
a lot of times we forget just how badass
we are
so what I do and I've done for so many
years I write down I've been writing so
this book right here
this is just about three year book but
I've been writing down for years what I
would do so open up to a page today look
at it
and I go through looking at 18 miles 16
miles 17 miles 15 miles 16. her 16 mile
week her 23 Mile a week 20 20 18 16 all
by myself trading alone
push us pull up sips all this [__] right
down here to remind me of the work I put
into the craft that is myself
so
we have to always remember
our purpose will always be there I have
nothing to firm you right now no race no
nothing but the purpose is myself
your mind has to be stronger than your
feelings
on those bad days when you think that
you're alone you just might be because
you know why no one else wants to do it
so you be the that always gets it done
what is the accountability mayor the
accountability mirror was you know I my
life I blamed everybody
and a lot of people have a lot to do
with my failures but it's now mine to
own I had to start owning this myself
because no you know they won't make
excuses for anything and everything
right you know my father wasn't coming
back the people that call me names
aren't coming back nothing was coming
back to save me so I realized I just
saved myself and I said you know what I
have to I have to make changes right and
that's when I invent the car building
mirror where I started putting down I'm
not smart and I put a sticky note on the
contemplation mirror
um this on that and my mirror was full
of sticky notes uh-huh and every day I
went through and I tried to kind of like
solve these problems right and the
biggest problem it was was trying to fit
in I was trying to fit in I was I was
blaming other people I wasn't taking
accountability for my own actions I was
I was doing all these things wrong as a
17 year old trying to teach yourself
this it was difficult yeah and it's no
ball from there but I ended up passing
that test I passed the ASVAB test
yeah
it's very routine I wake up every single
morning I run I don't care if there's
nobody's sleeping her
I'm running it
why because I hate too much
you don't believe
that before it's done
so basically every day
outside
it's hot as hot as cold as cold then I
go to the gym 45 days a week and then
every single
outfit
for the last six years I have stressed
out for two three
o'clock in the morning
foreign
I want to be a person that thrived under
great adversity I got obsessed with
watching Rocky platoon all these kind of
war movies and and these different
movies of people going through adversity
and always talk about what really
changed my mindset was two minutes and
13 seconds and I came home one day and
and Rocky was on or I think my my buddy
had it on at his house you know he he
taped a whole bunch of movies and
whatnot they had these two VCRs and they
would take movies and he was watching
Rocky and I was uh Rocky one was on
round 14 and I'm sitting there watching
this watching this guy who I wasn't
familiar with obviously get knocked down
and everybody was telling him his Corner
man was saying stay down all this stuff
and I saw the you know the the champion
who was Apollo Creed turned around with
his hands in the air like he had beaten
this guy and I saw this guy getting up
in the music and everything was just
perfect it was like it was like the
perfect storm for me the music was very
inspiring the moment with everybody
saying stayed down and he was getting up
and when I saw this guy get up he looked
like he was beat
beat the [__] he got up and when I saw
this Apollo Creed I learned to find out
it was Apollo Creed turn around and see
Rocky get up all I remember was this
great champion in Apollo Creed I
remember seeing his face and no not many
people look at the face of Apollo Creed
the way I did I looked at it as my God
man this guy looks totally defeated and
he looks like defeated because he saw
this guy get up because in that and that
right there was what I wanted to be so
just it was like two minutes 13 seconds
whatever it was that clip that scene was
it became my new mental vision is I
didn't care about winning I didn't care
about any of that I just wanted to go
the distance I wanted to have that kind
of heart that kind of character to
continue getting up in life and I
realized I had to become very
uncomfortable to develop that kind of
mindset I didn't want to be Rocky by any
means I just wanted to be the kind of
guy that continued to fight and to
continue to get up and not look for the
easy way out I wanted to find pride in
myself because I saw died in that guy
Rocky just by getting up just by the
mere fact of getting up after getting
this kicked out of him and I wanted to
feel that way so that's kind of that's
kind of where it started for me I wanted
to feel a ride what does a morning look
like for you at the moment if you've got
a routine of some kind yes I run every
single morning
so that's time you up when are you
waking up I'm up about five five thirty
so every morning starts with the Run
and that's because that's the one thing
I hate to do more than anything in the
world
so that's like my cup of coffee
and I'm all about armoring yourself
so the second you leave your house
and the second you open your phone the
second you do any of that you are now
letting in poison in cancer
so I make sure a lot of things you can't
avoid
so as I get up I start to armor plate my
mind and body like a person is going to
war you put your body armor on that's
what I'm doing on that run
I'm waking up and I'm giving myself all
this armor so when I come out in the
world now look at that phone I'm ready
I'm not waking up late I'm not rushing
around I'm not disorganized because I
know I'm gonna get hit in the mouth
there's a there's an art to getting hit
in the [__] mouth
and that is why these things are
important you have to wake up and you
have to give yourself belief you have to
give yourself confidence that it starts
with that run
so after the run
I come home I eat something small how
long is the Run typically at the moment
nowhere Under 12 miles
so 12 miles is the minimum and what are
you getting that done in how long it
depends right now I'm running a heart
rate so I'm doing it like 8 15s 8 30s
because I'm retraining right now because
I was on two for you zone two yeah
because of the leg surgery I had so I'm
going back starting from scratch so
anywhere from about an hour 30 to two
hours I run every day how did the
negative voice lead you to the weight
gain and kind of keep you in the sewer
as you said so the most important
conversation you'll ever have is the one
you have with yourself
you wake up with it you walk around with
it eventually you'll act on it
and my self-talk was most disgusting
self-talk of all time
so the sewer of my mind like I said you
have to go back in there and fix things
a lot of us are afraid like right now 20
years ago you wouldn't find me on this
show I was too embarrassed to tell you I
stuttered I lied all these different
things getting beat up getting bullied
whatever happened
but that's where the true transformation
starts to happen when you can look at
people anybody thousands of people one
person and say hey this is who I am
and this is where I have to fix myself
and this is where it really happened I
thought it happened when I was in you
know 19 18 years old trying to pass this
military test right it happened here
when I was almost 300 pounds spraying
for cockroaches making a thousand
dollars a month and you know people call
me dumb people my dad called me so many
things not even funny being beat
distribute me of all self-esteem
this is when I realized I was alone on
this Earth yeah I have God Alone on this
Earth and I have to fix everything so
this is where I started to develop an
indestructible mental toolbox a lot of
us run away from our fears sure
and we box ourselves in to uh a
lifestyle of this is all we can do right
because I'm afraid of everything outside
this box yeah so I'm comfortable inside
this box
I dropped the Box oh you did for the
first time I laughed mentally I jumped
the box and said hey I gotta come out
here and play everything I had gone
through I realized that the human mind
if you can put it in a very quiet calm
place
and get it to calm down and not be so
[__]
that you could possibly make this work
out for you how bad how bad are you
really
so I calm myself down and I had to make
this enormous thing small I had 30 more
miles to run and my body was in the
worst shape in my entire life the worst
pain I ever felt in my life so I broke
this 30 miles thing down I broke it down
to small chunks I caught my mind down I
had to get water had to get potassium
how to get sodium I had to stop being so
dizzy because I had to be able to stand
up
so
my business went away after about an
hour I was able to stand up now and I
was going around this track and like a
30-some minute mile
and I never get my crew person saying
hey
I got to mile 81.
it says you're not going to make the
time I had 24 hours and I was going so
slow taking so much time this is when I
realized
that the human mind once everything gets
connected Once the mind knows you're not
going to quit something
it's going to try to find more it's
going to try to give you more once it
realizes you're not going to take the
path of least resistance
you're going to stay here until it's
done
my mind and my body my spirit became one
for the first time ever
for the first time ever it became one
and I went to a level that I never
thought was humanly possible for myself
or anybody else
in that shape that I was in I was able
to run 19 miles
and I ran 19 miles at 100 miles I
actually did one more mile I did 101
miles in 18 hours and 56 minutes I'd
overcome so many obstacles in my life
and this was
the final Crucible for me
and I got through it and at the end of
this race with such Clarity to me and it
was just um
the most amazing thing I ever do in my
life you have to remind yourself we all
have a story we've all all of us have
gone through very hard times
but we were when we're in a hard time
our mind has a way of forgetting what
all we've overcome I have a way of
taking one second when I want to quit
and saying okay
you endured this so I look at my life
and how I came up as the ultimate
training ground versus most people look
at it as why woe is me God why exactly
why right I had to flip this upside down
and say hang on a second
God was training me to be born the
baddest men on the planet absolutely
right that's how he this was this was my
journey do you begin to realize how
mentally strong you are yes because
those things beat me sure but it didn't
kill me no no and I was able to work
around him and figure out ways through
it
so when I was in the worst time of my
life in hell week I looked at everybody
and said I'm the most trained person
here well that's the truth I've gone
through more mental torture than any
walk even fathom yeah so I'm looking at
the baddest people on the planet I'm
looking at him like this
you guys can't hold a stick so I started
looking at verses like I don't belong
here versus like I might be the best
person ever come here wow who could have
pulled this off who could have been
given a sewer to live in in their mind
and say okay at Birth I'm gonna put you
in the worst place on the planet Earth
and let me see if you can go to the top
of the mountain right with nothing right
but just hard work grit and figuring out
and not putting yourself back in the
dungeon every time something got hard so
that's what became my daily voice was
you really are the baddest person on the
planet bro some of you read
that I think about when it's hot outside
that is
sunny and 70. well not today
it's the reality if it's about 90
degrees 100 humidity but who gives
that being said
September 3rd
I have to have my book turned in
and when I realized I'm reading this
book a lot but I realize
I wasn't born
I made them
at the bottom of insecurities fear
self-doubt lies was me buried in the
fetal position
how about got out of that was
recognizing it being honest with it
being truthful with it and then fixing
it we like to live on social media with
lies about ourselves how great we are
get to the source and fix the problem I
read your book and you've overcome a lot
from your upbringing so my question is
when you stop blaming your dad and maybe
not forgave but when you stop giving him
the power away for why you were the way
you were what did that do for you as a
person and as a father well it did a lot
for me as a person it did it did a lot
for me as a as a person as a man as a as
everything so once you realize where you
come from so I was you know I went back
and I faced that I faced my father
and by facing my father
it allowed me to realize you know
because as you're growing up you know
you you may look at your dad or your mom
or whoever may be and it's like they're
not human or they're just evil no they
are human and they also came from you
know maybe a bad childhood so I was able
to really go through and really dissect
my father
and by me dissecting my father
I got a lot of answers on why I was so
weak why I was so pathetic well I didn't
want to go be better and but that said
though
my father's demons had to go somewhere
so they went to me and my brother and
they went to a lot of other people you
have to realize that you have to now
solve for your demons and solve for him
is free to move on so when you get that
kind of strength when you when you're
able to look at these demons eye to eye
and say I'm not going anywhere I'm going
to face you every single day
what happens is you start to callous
that mind
you start to realize that all the bad
things you went through it doesn't
matter anymore I know where I'm going
and I'm focused on getting there so it
just starts to end and once you stop
caring about what people think about you
and once you stop caring about where you
came from it was a bad place you become
very very dangerous very dangerous what
the hell you
know what you're attacking life
all I need is a miracle well guess what
that Miracle ain't coming
there is no perfect time to start you
gotta start now with changing your life
we're all being tested in life
and guess what this is one test you
can't cheat on
we all have our own death some of us are
old peace somebody's depressed
somebody's insecure in the military we
have this big old rucksack on the back
had batteries water extra gear the extra
gear is just you're dealing with in life
and the other way to overcome it is for
you or you alone to face it
you gotta do your best work when you're
at least motivated
those days you don't want to do it guess
what you gotta do you gotta suck it the
[__] up and do it stay hard I'm not a
very known athlete I'm not a
professional athlete I'm an underground
athlete uh I didn't do anything to
accept these amazing Awards I did it
because basically I grew up in very
tough tough life
um lived in a horrible Place mentally
physically emotionally spiritually got
beat down so bad my father that he beat
the courage and strength out of me
trying to find a way to kind of get it
back and how I did that was literally
examining my my soul so in doing that I
started looking for the most uncommon
people in the world so it brought me
into Special Operations
um from the Air Force to the seals to
Rangers and along the way I started
realizing how powerful the Mind truly is
and how little we use others so when I
was getting beat down I thought I was
nothing I thought it was the lowest form
on Earth
it's without my mindset what I did was I
started joining Special Operations unit
you know looking for these courageous
men and I found them and when I found
him I started realizing that it's all in
your head
the most important conversation is the
one you have with yourself you wake up
with it you walk around with it you go
to bed with it eventually you act on it
and my conversation was a bad one so the
people who I thought were up here in my
life these aren't common men I was
putting myself down here but of a period
of time I started realizing that I'm
also uncommon and I started pissing
those uncommon men off by realizing that
we all have this ability in our mind
talk to me about the accountability
mirror so the accountability mirror is
something that I
kind of came up with in high school
like I said I started shaving my head
when I was 16. and I got caught up in
trying to impress so many people because
no one liked me
so I developed so many different
identities let me Sag My Pants
you know let me okay let me pull my
pants up let me let me talk this way or
act this way or be this way or whatever
the hell it may be God dog there's so
many different things I did to try to
fit in with so many different groups
that
when you look in the mirror that's the
one person you can't lie to
every morning I would shave my head
thinking God I reflect back on some of
the lies I may have told somebody or
some of the ways I acted I didn't feel
comfortable doing and I did it to
impress other normal people
the key where there is normal everyday
people I was trying to make other people
like me how pathetic is that
so I this mirror would always tell me my
my reflection would say God you are a
pathetic man
how does that feel every day to be this
way so I would just start having myself
accountable how how did I attack today
how'd I attack yesterday
and if I didn't do something I was proud
of I write down the sticky note
and I would fix it
so then my senior year in high school
it was a totally different David Goggins
you work out every day you ever missed a
day I did it for the last 20 20 years of
my life 20 years 27 years no 20 some
years of my life when every day you work
out so
I used to take one day off a week I used
to take one day off a week about to
recover right it makes sense but that
one day off was an active recovery day
where I would get on a trainer and ride
for like two hours wow but at a at a
Zone one heart rate very low heart rate
and I replaced the carbohydrates in my
body while I rode because the best way
to recover for me is to do something at
a very low heart rate because Therefore
your blood's flowing through your body
yeah as your blood flow into your body
refuel it with the nutrients because
then your blood's flowing the nutrients
is going through all your cells in your
body all that glycogen is now flowing at
a low heart rate so it's not burning it
it's refueling it yeah so every Sunday
used to be that and it kind of
snowballed into as human beings
We Believe like so many people before I
give them a workout plan they're talking
about recovery everybody everybody that
hears me speak they want to go straight
to recovery
work out first huh
workout before you talk to me about
recovery Auto Recovery yeah work out
first so now you know that my knees are
messed up but that doesn't mean you
don't stop going you don't stop pushing
life's about improvise adapt and
overcome in every situation that's in
front of you a lot of people hate that
message that I say continue pushing
continue to find your new 100 continue
finding your best self if you don't like
that message this is not the place to be
I'm about people trying to find the best
they have not making excuses overcoming
any and all obstacles so today I can't
run I can't do much but you can
guarantee one thing David Goggins got
the faster he got the [__] after I don't
give a [__] my knees don't work I'll
find something else that does stay hard
what kind of advice can you give my team
anybody in the audience here who wants
to do better but it's just not happening
you know with the best advice tell
everybody about people who are trying to
get started people trying to get better
than anything in life the one thing that
kept me down for so many years was I had
these voices in my head enough
things now so basically the voice I had
in my head was of other people
who weren't trying to get where I was
trying to get and you know broken up the
way I grew up from having some people
believe myself
all these negative boys
it wasn't until I was able to
literally shut off every single voice
but my own
and stop being afraid of being a judge
special
black kids in the school and I was
trying to find my way and
how hard this kid
I would be the only black and being the
only in classroom I try to find the
furthest quarter away from everybody not
good so please don't
don't call I'm not smart it wasn't until
I started saying to myself you know what
who gives you [__] about who the judging
it is
so precious
it's the pressure you feel about
not ever judge you
pleasure you are the people
tried
there's a concept in your book that it
permeates the whole book and I think
really is one of the most important
things for people to understand in their
own life certainly to understand you and
it's the notion of the testing
mediocrity talk to me about that how do
you how did you instill it in your life
how can other people instill it in
theirs it's one of the biggest things in
the world a lot of us mediocrity is
everywhere right now and we're also
trying to find an easy way out and we're
judging ourselves let's say there's 10
people in this room and we're all
mediocre
but I'm the best
of the mediocre people
I now think I'm great
I'm great we surround ourselves around
people that make us feel great they tell
us what we want to hear the second we
put ourselves amongst the uncommon
people
we don't like that feeling that
challenging feeling that of that
person's wake up at 3 30 in the morning
hey put your shot we're going for a run
we don't like that challenge we like
that person who says hey you know what
man I don't feel good today man and they
say oh it's okay brother we'll take a
day off maybe get a pizza and watch the
game we like that we we love that
feeling why because you understand man
we're good bro we don't want that like
this hey man no bro get your [__] on man
stop being a punk we don't want that in
our lives we don't want that person
who's constantly challenging our
weaknesses we want that process
constantly you know making us feel nice
and good and secure in ours that's the
mediocrity of life we want to be the
best amongst the average people people
wonder how do you stay hungry all the
time
because after I accomplished something I
don't sit back like a lot of guys should
graduate budge graduate this graduate
that they get comfortable they wonder
why I'm getting weak man I don't know I
lost my Edge what's going on because
once you hit the top of the mountain
guess what happened
I'm good I'm good so you wonder why
you're falling down now because once you
be top of the mountain you gotta build
another one that's mediocrity there's a
lot of people in mediocrity who have a
nice resume
but they're one-timers man they hit they
hit a one-time deal they busted it open
got a lot of money but they're good
you're a mediocre now man what are you
doing today tomorrow the next day that's
why I'm listening to theorists I don't
listen all that [__] I listen to him
who's like this man
what's wrong ma'am tired dude why are
you tired because tomorrow I gotta do
the Finish again man whatever this [__]
is that made me nauseous and sick to my
stomach it made me hurt
there's no ending
and that's the person I listen to that's
the person who's gained knowledge you
gain knowledge through suffering and on
the other end the suffering is a world
that very few
very few have ever seen it's a beautiful
world because that's where you find
yourself
you don't find yourself in over here
you find yourself on the other end like
the 100 mile race I was on I ran it for
24 hours I found myself on the other end
of that race that 19 hours I found wow
there's a whole nother World out here
that I've never even saw the world's in
your mind
and that's when all that mediocrity is
about mediocrity is contagious I'm the
only person in Navy SEAL history to be
in three hell weeks in one year it
helped me because 130 hours of
continuous training I got into hell week
got double pneumonia stress fractures
got rolled back to day one week one I
broke my kneecap so I reported back to
day one of Navy SEAL training broken and
we had a guy die in my third hell week
so hell week ended about 30 hours early
I have severe stress fractures
my knee is now blown up again I knew I
wasn't gonna get a chance to go back
through hell week again I made a
decision to myself there's no more
quitting so that's when I went and got
duct tape
for the first 45 minutes the duct tape
hurt like hell but after 45 minutes my
legs would go numb once stuff goes numb
you can't feel it so that's how I went
through the rest of 22 more weeks of
Navy SEAL training
[Music]
I was already at Rock Bottom my whole
life so we know where our Rock Bottom
feels you'll mind sleeping in the sewer
so at that point once I realized that I
already experienced the bottom I no
longer had fear
of failure but this took a long time
it's one like I woke up oh Eureka I got
it I started realizing that the mind is
the most powerful weapon that we have
once I was able to quiet my mind and
realize that I was really not cursed but
blessed to have so many tools I never
saw as tools while growing up so much
hardship only thing could happen for me
now is this Victory I googled this race
called The Hurt 100. it's a hundred mile
run in Hawaii with 25 000 feet of
climbing only 27 people had ever
completed this race I didn't know any of
these stats ignorance is bliss
I show up there with compression tape on
because my feet are jacked up severely
bad
and
I show up I finished the race barely
call Chris Kaufman up get my application
in just in time he says you're an idiot
I cannot believe you went out to that
race and did it I get into the bad water
he says you know they select the top 90
athletes in the world I got fifth my
first year got came back got third ran 7
000 miles
in 2007 to raise over two million
dollars for Special Operations Warrior
Foundation and thank you
[Music]
assistant I'm getting inducted into the
International Sports Hall of Fame in
March
um I've done so many things I got the
VFW americanism award I beat Lance
Armstrong out in 2008 for the world's
fittest man I'm not on steroids but he
said he wasn't either so who knows
and just to leave y'all with this I
didn't get deep into the weeds because
I'd have much time up here
but I did everything I talked to you all
about with a hole in my heart the size
of a dime
so I didn't get deep about how sick I
was through hell week through Ranger
school through all these races I did I
thought it was just normal to be that
jacked up you're running I ran 205 miles
and 39 hours you're supposed to be
jacked up but not as bad as I was
basically everything I talked about
my heart so you know how you have the
good blood and the Bad Blood oxygenated
and deoxinated blood
my good blood was getting mixed in my
bad blood so I was working off about 60
of my capability
these doctors when they found it they
found it in 2009 while damn near died
because when you're in your 30s you have
a hole in your heart that's not real
good especially doing what I was doing
I'm not supposed to be in the military
so I snuck by thank God or maybe not who
knows
but long story short people is that a
whole bunch of these scientists and
doctors came out to study me I was like
a lab rat how did you do what you did
in one doc they couldn't find anything
genetically gifted about me like with
something just compensating for
something else how did you do this
one doctor sat back and said this guy
figured out all the tools of the Mind
and I take a lot of pride in that we all
have a lot more ability than we think we
have and we it's up to us to find it how
did you make the change and eventually
get into the military well I realized
with the Learned disability I was gonna
need a lot of help so my mom you know
got enough money to pay 15 a week for
one hour for a tutor to kind of come in
and help me out so my ritual became
pretty much study study study study work
out study study study work out and that
became my whole life so I went from this
character to a a very focused person and
the only way I can learn pretty much
even still to this day is through
repetitions I had to put so many
different reps in it it's absolutely
unreal and that's my real work ethic
began people think it's because of my
running and everything else in my
weightlifting it started with uh
literally just trying to learn how to
read and write and I had to literally go
to the store and we bought these spiral
well I bought these spiral notebooks and
we only had like I said an hour a week
so it's gonna take a lot more than that
to learn all of school in six months I I
had six months to learn all this to pass
this ASVAB test okay I felt it a few
times before so I had to get these
spiral notebooks and I literally had to
write down everything repeatedly in
these spiral notebooks to put it to
memorization and how I would pass these
tests is I really didn't know what they
were talking about during the test I
just memorized all these different
formulas and equations and just you know
different kind of spelling words and
different kind of paragraph
comprehensions and all these different
kinds I memorized all this stuff and
basically when it came time for the test
I remembered that I saw it on page 71 or
72 or 130 because I written down so many
times and I could just recall it from
that so I literally developed a
photographic memory through the kind of
work I put in behind you know my my
studies what's your purpose right now
our purpose right now is to continue
I used to have a wash rag and I did this
and you know how you take a shower you
have a wash rag in the cloth and you uh
you're sitting there and you're just
lathering up and before you hang your
rag up you want to get all the water to
come on it and you know get it all all
that you know all the suds out of it you
want to wring it out and you want to
hang it up
so my big thing is when I live my life
I want to make sure that when I'm dead
and gone that I ring that wash rag out
and that washback is my soul and I also
believe that we're going to end up one
day meeting the maker if you believe in
one
and I believe that maker knows
everything about you everything about
you no one else could be here and
talking to you knows everything
but you also have a choice to make
you have a choice to make we have
choices and the one thing that scares me
to death in my life is getting to heaven
and not being what I'm supposed to be
and I believe that God has a chart and
he looks at the chart and he puts it in
front of you and get to heaven he says
hey that's what you're supposed to be
and one of my biggest fears in life
was to see that chart
and not have every block checked off you
know I want to make sure that I'm
constantly pursuing whatever it is I'm
pursuing just to be the best I can't
just constantly grinding myself into a
fine powder you know and but doing it in
a smart way like I talked about you can
constantly grind yourself into a point
where you're just sick
there's a there's a happy medium of
grinding so that's that's that's my
purpose now to continue to push myself
so others can see what is possible I
think we need to rethink how we frame
failure like I don't even like that word
you know what I mean because it implies
such a Negative outcome or perspective
like there should be a different word
for it and then we wouldn't be so caught
up in it you know what I mean what you
said is so true that word doesn't bother
me because I look at it like you are
trying to say it failure is this a word
for me failure was me
having more information on how to
succeed that's all failure became to me
so I failed so much pull-up records
running events had to quit this Buzz
Rangers all this crap had to go back
through all that was was oh I failed
because of these reasons here go back to
the drawing board figure out the right
equation put it together go back fail
again oh but I got more information so
everything I was afraid of I made sure
to meet it right in the face and
overcome it what does a moaning look
like for you at the moment if you've got
a routine of some kind yes I run every
single morning
about five five thirty so every morning
it starts with the Run and that's
because that's the one thing I hate to
do more than anything in the world
so that's like my cup of coffee
and I'm all about armoring yourself
so the second you leave your house
and the second you open your phone the
second you do any of that you are now
letting in poison in cancer
so I make sure a lot of things you can't
avoid
so as I get up I start to armor plate my
mind and body like a person's going to
war you put your body armor on that's
what I'm doing on that run
I'm waking up and I'm giving myself all
this armor so when I come out in the
world now look at that phone I'm ready
I'm not waking up late I'm not rushing
around I'm not disorganized because I
know I'm gonna get hit in the mouth
there's an art to getting hit in the
mouth
and that is why these things are
important you have to wake up and you
have to give yourself belief you have to
give yourself confidence that it starts
with that run and you say that when
you're living in Hell the only way to
find your way out is to confront the
Devil Himself you know who was that
devil for you it took several years for
me to figure out who the devil was
and the devil was my father
the devil was my father but what I
didn't put and never finished
was the devil really was me
so what happened was I put all this
blame and trust me my father and a lot
of people had to do with my upbringing
on how it was but like I put in that
book no one's gonna come back and say
hey man I apologize maybe someone does
very few people will so at the end of
the day when all things are said and
done with
while my dad was the devil and I
believed that for a long time I had to
confront him and I confronted the devil
so what I thought was the devil I
realized that I was the true devil
I was the one holding me back I was the
one looking for the escape goat you know
I was the one looking for all these ways
to say it's okay David you're a loser
you're a born loser so it's okay
and I was hoping my dad was going to
give me that confidence confession
and he was a loser himself but then the
day when I left there I realized man
it's all me
my dad's [__] up my mom's [__] up
the people around me are [__] up
they're not gonna save you
you gotta save yourself my friend so
that's when all that reality hit me when
I went to Buffalo to see my dad another
drive home I was like man this rest of
your life is gonna suck
it is going to suck not because you're
going to be a loser but because you're
gonna finally start to win
and winning is not easy my friend there
are a lot of people that are listening
right now that either dealing with this
very issue that we're talking about when
we finally left Buffalo after all the
physical and mental beatings that my dad
handed out we left Buffalo and I went to
a to me even worse environment I went to
a very small town in Brazil Indiana
where there was about five black
families and in 1995 the KKK marched in
our fourth of July parade
so that being said it paints Brazil
Indiana that you know that's the town
I'm talking about in a very bad light
and there were a lot of good people in
this small town so I want to make that
very clear but what happens is when you
come from a very Broken Foundation yeah
your mind only sees hate and evil yeah
there was one time I was in my sophomore
year walked in my Spanish class to get
my notebook open my notebook up and
inside the notebook
someone drew a little character of me in
a stick figure hanging from you know
like that like a noose yeah or like a
Hangman game
at this time in my life I was a
sophomore and I had about a fourth grade
reading level because I cheated all
through school right all through school
I cheated because I realized I was going
to get put in a special school right so
I found a way to get by and that's how I
got by right so what I'm getting at is
all this between my stepfather getting
murdered or soon to be stepfather get
murdered all these things compounded
into the lowest of low self-esteem so
what started happening was I started
lying
I became a amazing liar because I wanted
people to like me yeah when you come
from a society like I did
I had zero self-esteem and I feared
things I had zero self-confidence and I
was looking for anything I could that I
could gravitate to so it was lying yeah
but that's when I realized and it was a
long process that without having
self-esteem you are done yeah that's the
number one thing you have to have in
your life a lot of people are listening
to this right now and a lot of people
probably feel and they're not worth they
probably feel like crap about themselves
what is something that you're able to
share with people that can help flip a
switch or is there anything you know or
do they just need to come to their own
realization they need to hit bottom they
need to go through some
first in order to get there like what
are your thoughts on that well you know
what's funny man is that I'm not
speaking for every big guy by any means
all of us big guys man we got some
serious demons you know I hung around
big guys and we are we all you know we'd
all break down and we started talking
about our personal lives and how that we
all are and you know hey why'd you
become big man we all had almost a
similar story of insecurities yeah and
you know walking around in the airport
looking like a a Gargantua man people
look at you differently and you get a
little more self-esteem so
I'm gonna be talking to a few of us out
there when I say this man the biggest
thing in life is you have to do is you
have to be proud of yourself
you have to start developing that
personal self-esteem
and it has to be something that it's an
internal thing
and it has to come from a lot of hard
work and dedication and you really have
to
I call it like like right now I see your
headphones on your head I walk around
life
with so-called headphones on my head man
I don't you know really wear them
obviously but I just have these ear
muffs on that I I silence out the noise
I silence out the Judgment I silence out
the self-doubt I silence out every all
the naysayers and you know those people
get in their head and then we start
getting her head and the most important
conversation we'll ever have is when we
have it ourselves and like you were
saying to yourself man I'm dumb I'm this
I'm not I was the same way so that's
what you're constantly repeating to
yourself and that internal conversation
man that's who you're gonna be
and uh my my biggest thing for these
people who are out here is honestly man
you have to start callousing over that
victim's mentality
you have to start building this mental
armor that no matter what anybody said
that you can be in a room full of a
million people
and all million can be like against you
and calling you names and whatever you
got this you know what Roger that you
can go [__] yourself man I know exactly
where I'm going I know exactly what I'm
doing and that's the kind of self-esteem
you have to build in yourself man in
this kind of society today because it's
it's tough it's tough out here nowadays
I talk about theorists I talk about
practitioners a theorist is a person who
reads a book doesn't do it reads a book
learns about something and then talks
about it
a practitioner is myself a practitioner
is a person like me I want to be an
expert in the mind a mental toughness
guy Beyond mental toughness the only way
to do that in my eyes is to put yourself
in Hell put in Hell repeatedly
repeatedly put yourself in hell and
study how you process it and that's how
I was able to come up with all these
different ways all these different tools
to to slow the Mind down inhale because
the mind just speeds up the Mind wants
to get out of the painful situation the
suffering it can't it can't process it
so that's what I realized by going
through all these different processes of
being in Hell weeks you know is it's
just I love them how the mind process is
in hell I started this crazy stress
routine and I literally have healed
myself through the discipline I had and
what people won't believe is I got to a
point where I stressed out for eight to
twelve hours a day so essentially like
most of your waking hours when you're
not working out stretching yeah and it
went from that to six hours a day then
from six hours a day to four hours and
the more it opened up so the hips is
there like a specific routine of
stretches that you would go through or
just sit and stretch at the whole big
routine a whole mess of like opening up
your abductors because your abductor
attached to your hips your hip flexors
your everything is attached at this
region hear your your midsection your
hips and my hips got so tight that I
couldn't even squat down I had so much
back pain so that's why another reason
why I started running running you stay
upright I couldn't squat anymore I
couldn't do any of that power lifting
stuff so I just only they can do is run
run didn't bother me too bad and he got
the point I couldn't run either and my
health got real poor then my spine was
collapsed and um I just got real sick
and basically I healed myself no doctor
can find out what's wrong with me so I
couldn't run a lot I couldn't do any
activity so I said no I'm gonna bury
myself in stretching and what happened
was I had the shoes not on the back of
my head the knot came from my spine
collapsing and getting Tighter and
Tighter and Tighter it developed fluid
or whatever long story short as I
started stretching out that bump started
going away and the smaller the bump got
the healthier I got and I was like what
in the world is going on so I was so I
shave every day so I would feel this
bump in the bump and you can see it
right now yeah no I can see it yeah most
people think everybody's a bumping it
back here my bump was like this big it
was huge and the more I stretch the more
it went away the more it went away the
more the healthier I got I was like now
so I'd be like I'm Gonna Keep On
stretching so my stretching became it
was crazy and I got healthier and I was
like my gosh I stress more and more and
more and now it's I've been doing it now
for three years I haven't missed a dance
Traction in three years the problem that
most of us have is we think that we're
all alone
we think they were the only ones going
through all this stuff I thought it most
of us think that if you're fat which I
was fat for a while you think you're the
only fat person in the world your your
vision becomes very narrowed
and what happened to me was all I did
was I peeled back
I pulled back and I was able to get on
top of a Mountaintop in my head and when
you're high on that mountain you have a
great you have a great vantage point
and I was able to look down at the world
and we are all of us are jacked up some
of us hide it better than others but
we're all jacked up and once you realize
that you know you got to come out of
your shell you gotta accept who you are
you got to accept the demons that life
gave you that maybe you gave you whoever
gave them to you you got to accept that
you can't be able to look him in the
mirror look him in the eyes okay I'm
gonna start fixing these things but if
you think that you're by yourself
the reality of your life becomes very
very horrible and you're not we are all
jacked up and once you realize that man
you just
it's like whatever
you know you don't even look at the
crowd anymore you look at your own race
you do your own race you do your own
thing and you finally found out who
you're supposed to be in this life the
one second decision is I had to live
through that one second decision several
times during this race
so this race
took me a hundred and some hours okay
and this is what people don't get
for you to finish that race even though
I dnf'd I still finished in the time
so there's a lot of pride in that so
what I do in that one second because we
all think about quitting it's hard
but what you have to do in that one
second is hard to process information
during pain
because that pain takes over
and you can't think rationally
you're thinking about fight or flight
save yourself that's not a rational
thought it's not a thought that's going
to get you through
hard times
most people fail that one second so what
happens what I do in that one second and
there's a bigger process to all this but
in that one second
I physically stayed in that water
because if I get out of the water I quit
so I physically stay in the water but
mentally
I'm on the beach with the instructors
and the instructors it's cold outside so
they got these Parkers on they got their
cup of Joe and they're warm because
they've already been through it so now
it's your turn to go through it
so merely I get back with them I'm still
in the water physically but mainly I'm
back with you I'm chilling I got my
Parker on and now I'm thinking logically
because I'm warm now mentally I'm warm
I've taken that one second
let's not quit yet guys let's think
about your options
where are you going to end up if you
quit this where are you going to go
where are you going to say to yourself
because you know you're going to get
warm the second you get out of this
water you're gonna take a shower
and you can be warm and you could be and
in five days you could be out so I start
thinking logically
I calm my brain down because your brain
just wants to get the [__] out ring the
bell push your helmet down get warm and
then you really
and these are the things you have to
think about the one second decision
so that's what that's all about it's
about gaining control of your mind
putting things back in the proper
perspective
and then saying
I really do want to be here
and I'm gonna have a bunch of these one
seconds through this 130 hour Journey
and I have to learn to control these
because if I fail one of these one
seconds I will not be a seal I will not
be a doctor I will not be a lawyer I
will not be whatever the [__] it is so
that's how important that one second
decision is it's all about your mind
taste control you you have to say [__]
you
I run this
and that's what that's all about you
talk about the importance of having the
right people in the Foxhole with you how
do you know who the right people are
you know what that's that was something
to me a lot of years to figure out
you know you're the right people in your
Foxhole
when you're waking up at three o'clock
in the morning you're going to bed at
midnight and you're waking up at three
and no one says is this smart to do you
need some time off you need to take a
break
when I start hearing that well I know
what I'm doing to myself
I was behind the power curve man when
everybody starts off in first grade
I had them negative grades
I start off in the dungeon but I had to
dig out of the damn grave to get the
first grade so now when you're 20 years
old where everybody graduated high
school and all sorts man I gotta make
time up
so while people think 24 hours is one
day for me it's three four five days
I gotta make up time I'm behind I gotta
go to summer schools in my mind
who's with me realizes this has got to
go to summer school in his mind he's got
to make up time he needs 22 hours of the
24.
and they just get it he's trying to go
somewhere
you are the right person for my Foxhole
I don't want to hear no [__] about
resting I can't rest right now I'm
hearing about what I'm doing to myself I
know what I'm doing to myself
did you see how I came up I gotta catch
up now
and that's what life is about sometimes
you are raised in a position where you
are behind
we have to make that time up
I'm sorry it may be inhumane you may be
unbalanced it may not look right to you
I don't give a [__] it's the situation
that life put me in and I need people to
say when I don't want to give at three
in the morning I need my life that see
me go to bed at 12 it wakes me up at
three
saying you need to get this done
that's the Foxhole I don't need
critiquing I need pushing I need pulling
I need anger I need passion I need Drive
I need them man those bad days I don't
need somebody in my ear saying
man
because then that's all a person needs
is that support can go a lot of ways man
it can go a lot of ways
so this is where the 40 rule comes in
people worse shaped my entire life I've
been through Ranger school of Delta IV
selection twice three hell weeks all
this crap this is the worst pain I've
ever been in to this day I'm 43 years
old right now to 21 years in the
military I've done 60 Ultra races
pull-up records all kind of stuff this
is the worst pain of my entire life to
this day but this is what I had to
realize one thing I had to break this
humongous thing down to very small all I
put in my mind was let's not quit yet
I'm gonna quit but not yet so I sat
there I can't stand up so let's get some
nutrition
all right I'm not dizzy anymore
let me clean this crap off me okay I
need some food I'm gonna quit after
eating peanut butter and jelly sandwich
all right but not yet
let me see if I can stand up stand up
maybe I'll quit let me see if I can walk
to the car there's the car it's a one
mile track I'll walk past the car I'm
just gonna get back to the chair
I'm not gonna quit yet I kept this
mindset the whole time
I ended up doing 30 more miles
did 31 miles truly after that I did 101
miles in 19 hours if you drive the car
the car may say 130 miles an hour
the factory puts a governor on it so it
only go 91. so he's sitting there with a
race somebody they have no Governor
they're fine boom you can't because
every time you get to 91 the car starts
doing this it starts doing this we put a
governor on our brain and the second we
get to that Governor our body start
doing this oh this sucks this is
uncomfortable no no no no no let's go
this way let's stop
it starts giving you all these questions
that we cannot answer if you can't
answer the questions your brain is
asking you you quit if you have the
answers to those questions of why the
hell am I out here and you give it a
quick answer the brain starts shutting
up because it knows why we're doing what
we're doing I started figuring these
things out in my life
so we have this governor on our brain
and how you start pushing past that
Governor start realizing your brain has
the Tactical advantage over you why
because it knows your insecurities it
knows when you're lying it knows your
fears knows everything about you let me
ask you something what does it mean to
you to be referred to as the toughest
guy in the world and to be called the
gold standard an extraordinary and
superhuman and all of these different
descriptions of you that make it sound
like you're a one-off that it's almost
unattainable uh what you've done with
your life what does that mean to you in
terms of your message
I mean I guess the you know the the
whole hardest man in the world thing
um
that you know you can call what you want
but that that title came from where I
came from
and you know it's like you know I have
limited Horizons
so if you were to have a million people
in a room
and you had all of their resumes like
from the age of one to the age of 20.
you would never pick me being where I
you know where I am now
and that's where the hardest man in the
world came from was you know how many
people can come from where this man
started to where he is now so it wasn't
really so much about yeah all the
physical Feats you know going through
you know still training three times and
range of school and all these things
I've done that helped give me that title
but the biggest reason I got that title
was because when I realized you know I
was a fallback Clan I just refused to
give up and the thing about that Chris
is like more like I figured this out
most of us are only one to ten percent
away from greatness
but we think we're so far away from it
that we never try
and once I start going down this journey
I started realizing that and those
percents started to add up and before I
knew it my mind started hardening and I
started passing so many different people
I thought were so far above me and then
before I knew it man
I became a common amongst the uncommon
belief is something it's not I can't
tell you oh believe in yourself that's a
bunch of crap
belief came for me
was going through those hell weeks
taping those legs up getting up early in
the morning by myself no coach getting
myself up
motivating myself every single day when
I'm out there in 240 mile runs and I
don't want to be out there and I'm 90
miles into it and I have 150 miles to go
and no one's there saying come on David
I'm forming belief
many people form belief in many
different ways
for me this is how I do it some of those
Hard Times come my way
I know exactly how to get through them
when I first saw so I self-published my
book can't hurt me no one believed in me
I believed in myself
I sold them with five million copies of
that
now I never finished this case it's
coming out December 6th
never finished I guarantee you
the audiobook will probably go now it's
probably one of the best audio books
it sounds cocky as hell
of all time it's truly amazing what we
put into that book because of how I've
lived my life
a lot of people come up here and speak
about motivation and pushing yourself
and you're not doing it
they're now waking up every single day
they have a canned speech they go off
and they tell you about about what to do
how to do it wake up every morning make
your bed take a cold shower all that
crap
I'm telling you right now
you have to be that person that leads
from the front many of you out here are
in leadership positions
and many of our leaders right now are
not leading from the front they're
leading from the rear but they're
telling you
how to do it
they're waking up late
they're not doing what they say
so when life is real important to do
what you say because that's where true
knowledge comes from
and when I wasn't going through Navy
SEAL Traders one thing I told myself
I wanted to quit every single day
but many dreams die while suffering
and many of us out here have suffered
and when you're suffering I'm not
talking about just physically I'm
talking about emotionally spiritually it
can be a relationship when you're
suffering you give up on the very things
that you want it the most
when I was going through pear rescue I
wanted to be a prayer rescue man so bad
but that water haunted me
so when the suffering got too much my
dream died
and pretty much I almost died with it if
I didn't find Navy Seals and getting
past that hump and overcoming my demons
and facing my demons every day I would
have never been up here today
you can't outrun your demons
they'll always know where you're hiding
trust me at that
and I'm in with this
don't stop when you're tired
stop when you're done have you tried to
control how you feel how you react to
people and go jealousy hate you know
whatever and trying some kind of Mastery
of that do you see that as different to
the mind
jealousy 100 you have to if you're
jealous about anything that is a
horrible thing
um anger
I've done really well with controlling
it nowadays back in the day when you're
insecure so all this stuff comes from
conquering yourself
once you feel good about yourself
all the anger not all of it we're human
jealousy these things start to really go
away she's like you know I'm good yeah
I'm good I'm a very emotional person
so I'm very passionate
because it took a lot for me to be who I
am today so I'm very emotional yeah but
it's just the passion in me about the
sacrifice I put into being who in the
day so and sometimes that spills over
sometimes you lose control of it it's
not losing control I allow it to go
so I got this award for the BF
BF Bob the americanism
of war and I'm speaking in front of like
5 000 veterans
and I get the award and I'm thanking
people and I turn back to my mom I look
at her
and
for 58 seconds just cried
because I had a chance at that time to
look and see what I've accomplished and
where I came from and
I wasn't trying to hold it but to get
myself together to get my speech
but it was a very proud moment for me to
be able to reflect and say okay man like
you know you've not like I've earned
that right to cry or to be emotional but
it felt good
that literally I grinded myself into a
fine powder to get where I'm at today
and it just came out in that way so yeah
emotion is a beautiful thing you don't
want to if if you're emotional that's
bad yeah but if you show emotion at the
right time I think that's a that's a
beautiful thing so it's still a an
essence of controlling it yes yeah
because you have to you want to be in
control of your mind
be in control of your mind emotional
people
their wreck um they control that emotion
controls your everything you do yeah and
what emotional people do is
like for instance I always say this they
can have a beautiful life
husband and wife kids everything
everything they want
but it's the one thing that they don't
have that makes them emotional so that
emotion makes them focus on what they
don't have emotion makes them focus on
everything negative
everything pity party what was me this
didn't happen so your mind loves that
it loves talking to other people how
this is all [__] up man you know think
about it people love to complain about
everything so when you're sitting there
you may spend weeks months years about
the same thing
so what have you done nothing there's no
solution in that yeah but most of us
live there oh this other guy got the pay
raise the other guy got this other guy
got that and we live in this emotional
state of what was me nothing gets
accomplished hi David what do you think
about people who are using exemptic for
weight loss
um you know what I'm all about people
doing what they need to do in life that
said
um I think that they're missing a big
part of weight loss
for me you know I lost 106 pounds I was
almost three years I was 297 pounds
and the weight loss Journey itself is a
journey
it takes you through this maze it's not
a straight line it takes you to this
Maze of emotions one day you may lose
the power one day you may gain a pound
it's a fight
and the only way you get better is
through the fight through the struggle
if you do things like that oh I lost it
real quick you're not getting the full
benefit of the hard work that it took to
get there and through that hard work
you don't forget that you don't forget
those months those years it took all
those workouts all those all those uh
diets drinking tons of water going to
bed early when people go out to dinner
you gotta ask the chef to make the your
your damn meal special all those things
are not fun
and that is where you grow so when you
take these weight loss pills do what you
want I don't give a damn but what
happens is you missed the biggest part
the biggest part of the weight loss is
what happens to your mind along that
horrible Journey
so I got stronger I got better if you
want to take the weight loss pills do
you so that's what I think about it
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Jocko willink motivation
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there The Chronic
excuse maker how do you stop making
excuses
this is actually pretty simple
and I said it the other day and you have
to realize you have to know